[Música]
vamos a nuestra revista de prensa con
Marta Moya Marta un buen día para usted
Hola Ángela feliz martes amanecimos
Marta hoy con la noticia de nuevos
bombardeos en la guerra abrimos por eso
nuestra revista de prensa con este tema
de Ucrania Este martes hubo ataques con
drones tanto en Moscú como en kiev y
Comencemos si le parece con lo que dicen
los medios rusos sobre lo que ocurrió en
su capital Así es Ángela vamos a
destacar cuatro medios rusos empezamos
con nos vaya gaceta este medio
independiente que repasa un poco lo que
ha sucedido esta mañana en Moscú
sostiene este artículo que hemos
destacado que los primeros reportes se
han dado a las 7 de la mañana hora local
a través de las agencias de noticias
rusas tass y riano bosti media hora más
tarde a las 7:30 el alcalde de Moscú
sergeynin confirmó estos ataques que han
afectado a varios edificios de la
capital rusa sufriendo Según dice el
daños menores no han dejado ni muertos
heridos pero de
o sea de gravedad leve perdón y según el
comunicado del Ministerio de defensa
ruso el ataque se ha dado con ocho
drones cinco de ellos han sido
desactivados por las defensas antiaéreas
rusas y tres se han desactivado por la
guerra electrónica han afectado No sobre
edificios de Moscú sino también a aldeas
aledañas a la capital rusa y según el
comité de investigación de ese país ya
han comenzado Las investigaciones para
dilucidar Cuáles han sido los motivos de
este ataque hemos destacado también el
medio independiente medusa que dice que
Fuentes cercanas a la presidencia dicen
a este medio que lo de hoy ya era
previsible tras los ataques al kremlin
el pasado 3 de mayo el efecto de estos
hechos es más psicológico que Real al
menos de momento recoge también unas
declaraciones del Ministerio de defensa
acusando a kiev al régimen concretamente
de kiev de estos como dicen ellos
ataques terroristas y también des las
palabras del asesor de zelensky de
mijael podoliac que ha dicho
textualmente Quizá no todos los drones
estén listos para atacar a Ucrania y
quieran volver con sus creadores hemos
destacado también al medio día domosti
que destaca que la fiscalía general de
Rusia ya ha advertido sobre la gravedad
de que se generen fake news a raíz de
los ataques en Moscú y que cualquier
noticia poco fidedigna va a ser
perseguida por las autoridades Y por
último hemos destacado el medio muy al
final
keremlindra que ha utilizado un tono
mucho más beligerante y ha dicho
textualmente si el régimen ucraniano es
capaz de llegar a alguna parte
definitivamente
intentará hacerlo ha acusado
directamente al líder de la inteligencia
militar ucraniana kiril budanov de estos
ataques y ha dicho que solo se pueden
repeler con la rendición del régimen de
kiev sabe que me parece muy positivo que
en los informativos solo podemos vamos a
dar uno dos o tres datos Y tenemos que
pasar a la noticia siguiente aquí vemos
un poco más o nos da más la sensación de
cómo se vive en vivo y en directo este
tipo de episodios Pero en qué como hemos
dicho tampoco han quedado exentos de más
ataques y es que si bien sorprenden los
que sucedieron en Moscú no sorprenden
para nada los de la capital ucraniana y
esto nos lo reportan medios de ese país
Así es Ángela y hemos destacado tres
medios ucranianos empezamos con el
ucranisca Prada que también repasa un
poco lo que ha sucedido en kiev en las
últimas horas concretamente la capital
ucraniana ha sido nuevamente víctima de
un ataque a gran escala con drones rusos
shared que se han saldado con al menos
la vida de una persona han dejado cuatro
heridos y han atacado también
infraestructura civil en diferentes
puntos de la capital esta incursión
aérea sostiene este artículo de
lucanista ha sido de 3 horas según la
inteligencia
bueno ha provenido de diferentes
direcciones y en varias oleadas es el
ataque número 17 en lo corrido del mes
de mayo y por otra parte destacamos un
artículo del kiev independent que dice
que es el tercer ataque a kiev en las
últimas 24 horas las defensas antiaéreas
de quiet han logrado derribar 20 drones
en este último ataque de las fuerzas de
Moscú y este ataque Eso sí dejó un
incendio por lo que podría haber más
víctimas mortales porque se han
derribado los pisos Superiores de uno de
los edificios residenciales Y por último
hemos destacado el Kids que dice que las
sirenas antiaéreas han empezado a sonar
Este martes a las 2 de la madrugada en
kiev en el centro de kiev concretamente
se han empezado a escuchar según
reporteros de este medio los clásicos
estruendos de los drones kamikaze de
fabricación iraní con los que cuenta
Rusia todo esto ya después de un ataque
en la noche de ayer hay otro ataque con
misiles en el día de ayer también se han
reportado según este artículo ofensivas
con misiles y con drones en las ciudades
sureñas de odesa y de nikolife y hemos
destacado por finalizar una viñeta
también en el kievs Que firma el
caricaturista sergi colida en la que se
ve a Vladimir Putin diciendo que lancen
más misiles sobre kiev con una aparente
cara de frustración por la inutilidad
presuntamente de estos ataques y el post
titula El tirano trastornado del kremlin
histérico por el éxito de las defensas
aéreas de Ucrania bueno es que todos nos
estamos preguntando a cuento de que van
estos ataques Más allá de la angustia
que generan en la población vamos a
cambiar de tema Marta con una exclusiva
del británico de Garden que afirma que
el líder de la cop28 que sabemos se
celebrará en abu dabio a finales del año
ha utilizado a su equipo para blanquear
su imagen a pesar de que tiene vínculos
directos con fósiles cuéntenos más Pues
sí Ángela está exclusiva del británico
de Garden sostiene que bueno el líder
designado por emiratos árabes Unidos
para la cop 28 que se va a celebrar en
noviembre en ese país El Sultán al
llaver pues está acusado de lavar su
imagen a través de su equipo utilizando
o editando páginas de Wikipedia cuando
este tipo por ejemplo controla la
industria de los combustibles fósiles en
el país ha trabajado la expansión
concretamente de la producción de
combustibles pese a las constant o los
constantes llamados de la agencia
internacional de energía para que no se
sigan desarrollando estos proyectos para
lograr las emisiones de carbono cero
para el año 2030 además también
sostiene esta exclusiva de de Guardian
que este tipo El Sultán al saber también
firmó en 2019 un acuerdo multimillonario
con inversores estadounidenses para
llevar a cabo la construcción de un
oleoducto Y entonces a partir de ahí su
equipo estaría blanqueando todas estas
informaciones editando páginas de
Wikipedia y tildandolo además
editándolas a su favor diciendo que es
el mayor Aliado del movimiento climático
las consecuencias de esto 130
legisladores de Estados Unidos ya han
pedido la renuncia del líder de la cop28
y además nos da otra vez muestra de lo
vulnerable que es una página que
utilizamos tanto todos como es Wikipedia
y lo fácil que es inventarse realidades
o editarlas al antojo de quien pues
edita estas notas no y lo vulnerables
que son las negociaciones contra el
cambio climático Marta esto nos muestra
lo lento Que vamos pese a las grandes
pompas que anuncian los líderes
internacionales muy rápidamente vamos a
cerrar con una interesante carta de la
editora de financial Times que habla
sobre el uso de la Inteligencia
artificial desde ese medio si Ángela nos
referimos a rula calaf que es la editora
del financial ha dicho que lo más
importante para este medio es mantener
la confianza de los lectores con los
preceptos de calidad precisión equidad y
transparencia que la Inteligencia
artificial tiene potencial para aumentar
la productividad en el interno de la
redacción pero que nuestro periodismo
seguirá Y esto es textualmente siendo
informado escrito y editado por humanos
que son los mejores en sus campos se
valdrán de la Inteligencia artificial
para facilitar tareas como extracción de
datos o análisis de textos imágenes y
traducción pero se niegan a publicar
imágenes con Inteligencia artificial
porque según acaba esta carta la
tecnología Abre nuevas y emocionantes
fronteras que deben explorarse con
responsabilidad y cautela ante la
desinformación y la corrupción de la
verdad pues una buena noticia gracias a
usted Marta gracias Ángela Hasta mañana
hasta